[Music]
Google flower just moved into your
neighborhood
hi and namaste I'm an ish I leave the
customer engineering team in India and
Asia helping customers migrate to Google
cloud we're seeing huge demand for
Google cloud in India with customers
like hight Danny Parker Ashok Leyland in
shots and one not to name a few
this is the reason why we and our
customers are so excited to see the
launch of a new region in Mumbai India
for the first time ever GCP users can
process and store data in India our
services include compute big data
storage and networking this new India
region has everything that you need to
build and scale it has been an amazing
journey to onboard hike as a customer
who are running their entire
infrastructure an analytics platform and
Google cloud to run the cross-platform
instant messaging service and love
working within shots so using Google
compute engine to power the news content
delivery mobile application the new
region in Mumbai means speed a
performance testing of the Mumbai region
shows 50 to 90 percent reduction in
latency when serving customers in India
as compared to other GCP regions in Asia
like Singapore and Taiwan GCP is the
smart secure cloud that will move your
business forward with the opening of the
new Mumbai region Google is your new
neighbor
right here right next door
you
[Music]